[Musique]
donc atteint
dix ans après l' attaque meurtrière les
souvenirs du drame sont encore présents
dans cette école juive toulousaine
appelé par sa fille en état de choc
quelques instants après les coups de feu
ce parent d'élève est l'un des premiers
à être arrivés sur les lieux ma première
réaction ça a été de
2,2 d'aller toucher les corps sur
l'autre tour pour voir s'il y avait
encore de la vie puis rentrer dans
l'école et voir encore de deux petits
corps quoi voilà ça a été ma première
réaction ensuite d'une fois que j'ai
fait ça je suis allé tout de suite
retrouvé ma fille et ses camarades bas
ici où nous sommes allés tâche de cette
synagogue et voilà je leur ai demandé de
faire l'appel de ceux de se compter
après le bal et les secours et des
enquêteurs
le soutien aux élèves aux professeurs et
aux familles s'organisent
des groupes de parole et une cellule de
soutien psychologique sont mises en
place un terme dans l'établissement
jonathan chétrite étaient présents lors
de l'attentât comme une thérapie il a
tout de suite couché sur le papier ce
qu'il a vu et ressenti il décrit avec
précision sa dernière vision de la
petite myriam huit ans une des quatre
victimes abattues par le terroriste ce
jour-là elle chantait et sauty et c'est
marrant parce que si je les écris c'est
que forcément on se l'est vu ou entendu
chanter
également appelé par
m
ce témoignage d'adolescents il l'a
transformé en livre un ouvrage pour
lequel il a interrogé d'autres anciens
de l'école la vie qu'on avait avant
cette visite peu fait classique de
lycéens
qui est ponctuée par des petites
disputes entre copains copines
et les histoires qu'on peut connaître
elle a forcément été
elle a été balayée a été balayée ça a
été un réel choc trois jours après
l'attaqué les cours reprennent
progressivement en plus de l'encadrement
médical l'équipe pédagogique a aussi
voulu changer les idées des élèves en
organisant toujours plus d'activités
extérieures seul le voyage prévu cette
année là au camp de la mort d'auschwitz
a été annulée car jugé trop pesant dans
ce contexte là par exemple on était la
cité de carcassonne le cross de l'école
chaque année des visites d'arcachon
ouvrir l'esprit des élèves leur faire
découvrir le monde et comprendre le
monde c'était un des objectifs de notre
directeur et dans notre projet
pédagogique me réhausser barbelés
vidéosurveillance
le collège-lycée confessionnelle a des
airs de forteresse la peur d'être visées
n'a pas disparu au milieu de la cour une
sculpture en hommage aux quatre victimes
tuées ici le 19 mars 2012
aujourd'hui on vit toujours dans la
crainte
pour sa enfin il faut que vous sachiez
que tous les matins devant l'école des
enfants il ya des militaires ce qui est
quand même
quelque chose de très marquant nos
élèves nos enfants sont élevés avec des
militaires devant la porte de l'école ce
qui est quand même inconcevable quelque
part quand on prend un peu de recul dans
un pays démocratique comme en france
après la tragédie léon ligne ani a perdu
le sommeil pendant plusieurs mois de
cette période il a gardé des dizaines de
journaux as et c'est toute la
revue de presse de ce qui s'était passé
donc à 10 ans que j'ai voulu garder
en souvenir mais en
transmission et aujourd'hui je le
ressors pour la première fois depuis dix
ans pour sa fille clara l'attentât a été
un déclic une fois son bac en poche elle
quitte la france direction israël avec
cinq autres camarades de classe c'était
pas c'était pas quelque chose de
d'établi pour elle le fait de faire son
ca à l'ia
après sa première étape d'études
mais c'est devenu évident du jour ou si
ces produits ça
c'est évident que ça vit maintenant et
là bas après on peut on peut pour rien
présager dans la vie mais bon elle est
totalement intégrée comme la fille de ce
graphiste et ses amis beaucoup de jeunes
qui ont vécu l'attentât ont choisi de
partir des familles entières ont aussi
fait leurs bagages le crif le conseil
représentatif des institutions juives de
france estime qu environ 30% des juifs
toulousains auraient quitté la ville
rose depuis dix ans